Voiceover:Say you're out
flying kites with a friend
and right at this moment
you're 40 meters away from your friend
and you know that the length of the kite's
string is 30 meters,
and you measure the angle
between the kite and the ground
where you're standing
and you see that it's a 40 degree angle.
What you're curious about is
whether you can use your
powers of trigonometry
to figure out the angle between the string
and the ground.
I encourage you to pause the video now
and figure out if you can do that
using just the information that you have.
Whenever I see, I guess,
a non right triangle
where I'm trying to
figure out some lengths
of sides or some lengths of angles,
I immediately think
maybe the Law of Cosine
might be useful or the Law
of Sines might be useful.
So, let's think about which one
could be useful in this case.
Law of Cosines, and I'll
just rewrite them here.
The Law of Cosine is c squared is equal
to a squared plus b squared
minus 2ab cosine of theta.
So what it's doing is it's relating
3 sides of a triangle.
So a, b, c to an angle.
So, for example, if I do 2 sides
and the angle in between them,
I can figure out the third side.
Or if I know all 3 sides,
then I can figure out this angle.
But that's not the situation
that we have over here.
We're trying to figure
out this question mark
and we don't know 3 of the sides.
We're trying to figure out an angle
but we don't know 3 of the sides.
The Law of Cosine just doesn't seem,
at least in an obvious way,
that it's going to help me.
I could also try to find this angle.
Once again, we don't know all 3 sides
to be able to solve for the angle.
So maybe Law of Sines could be useful.
So the Law of Sines, the Law of Sines.
Let's say that this is,
the measure of this angle is a,
the measure of this angle is lower case b,
the measure of this angle is lower case c,
length of this side is capital C,
length of this side is capital A,
length of this side is capital B.
The Law of Sine tells us
the ratio between the sine
of each of these angles
and the length of the opposite side
is constant.
So sine of lower case a over capital A
is the same as lower
case b over capital B,
which is going to be the same as
lower case c over capital C.
Let's see if we can leverage that somehow
right over here.
We know this angle and the opposite side
so we can write that ratio.
Sine of 40 degrees over 30.
Let's see. Can we say
that that's going to be
equal to the sine of this angle over that?
Well it would be, but we
don't know either of these
so that doesn't seem like
it's going to help us.
But, we do know this side.
Maybe we could use the Law of Cosines
to figure out this angle,
because if we know 2 angles of a triangle,
then we can figure out the third angle.
So let's do that.
Let's say that this angle
right over here is theta.
We know this distance right
over here is 40 meters,
so we can say that the
sine of theta over 40,
this ratio is going to be the same
as the sine of 40 over 30.
Now we can just solve for theta.
Multiplying both sides times 40,
you're going to get, let's see.
40 divided by 30 is 4/3.
4/3 sine of 40 degrees is
equal to sine of theta,
is equal to sine of theta.
Now to solve for theta,
we just need to take
the inverse sine of both sides.
So inverse sine of 4 over
3 sine of 40 degrees.
Put some parentheses here,
is equal to theta.
That will give us that angle here
and we can use that information
and this information
to figure out the angle
that we really care about.
So, let's get a calculator out and see if
we can calculate it.
Let me just verify, I am in degree mode.
Very important.
All right, now I'm going
to take the inverse
sine of 4/3 times sine of 40 degrees,
and that gets me,
and I deserve a little bit of a drum roll,
58, well if we round to the nearest,
let's just maintain our precision here.
So 58.99 degrees roughly.
This is approximately
equal to 58.99 degrees.
So, if that is 58.99 degrees,
what is this one?
It's going to 180 minus
this angle's measure
minus that angle's measure.
Let's calculate that.
It's going to 180
degrees minus this angle,
so minus 40,
minus the angle that we just figured out.
Actually I can get all of our precision
by just typing in second answer.
So that just says our previous answer
so I get all that precision there
and so I get 81.01 degrees.
So, if I want to round to the nearest,
let's say I want to round
to nearest hundredth
of a degree, then I'd say 81.01 degrees.
So this, this right over here,
is approximately 81.01
degrees and we're done.